bonjour gabriel jean marie bonjour
monsieur le temps merci d'être avec nous
ce matin dans son caddie très tôt dès le
mois de novembre dernier combat ouvrier
avait annoncé son intention de présenter
des candidats aux législatives de juin
prochain vous vous irez dans le sud il y
aura alex duféal dans le nord j sten
joie chez arnaud à fort-de-france et
marie-hélène marques dites sur elie dans
le centre atlantique home on peut dire
combat ouvrier respecte tout ce qui se
dit autour de la parité au delà même de
respecter ce qui se dit autour de la
parité c'est de proposer des
candidatures aux défendre un faire
entendre la voix des travailleurs faire
entendre le camp des travailleurs est ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que les
candidatures de combat ouvrier
s'inscrivent dans un combat plus global
plus générale puisque il y à la
présidentielle en france avec notre
camarade natalia antheaume de lutte
ouvrière
et puis les législatives dans la foulée
donc c'est un combat plus général alors
faire entendre la voix des travailleurs
c'est pourtant ce que certains de vos
candidats de vos collègues vos camarades
de vos compagnons font tout au long de
l'année dans leurs luttes syndicales au
jour le jour au quotidien
alors ce pas seulement les luttes
syndicales par exemple vous avez suivi
n'ya pas longtemps la lutte chez
fontaine didier la lutte chez casino
plaza batelière et beaucoup d'autres
luttes qui chronopost par exemple dans
tout au long de l'année effectivement et
notre objectif c'est de faire comprendre
que il ya les élections nous en
profitons pour proposer un programme
politique aux travailleurs mais c'est
surtout de dire que l'option la vraie
solution ce sont les luttes et plus il y
en aura puis il ya des luttes
importantes plus les travailleurs se
donnant les moyens de faire aboutir
leurs revendications ils ont leur
programme la lutte contre le grand
patronat le gros patronat comme vous
dites et je ne sais pas s'il y un grand
patronat un gros patronat je sais qu'il
ya un patronat il y à un système une
économie libérale système capitaliste
qui en fonction des
dd intervenants d'aider les employeurs
bons peuvent avoir une surface
financière plus ou moins importante
c'est vrai mais il n'empêche que c'est
toujours pareil il s'agit de se battre
contre eux effectivement le patronat les
contrôles des politiciens qui selon vous
mon ambition que d'être des serviteurs
de ce grand patronat absolument mais il
coûte t il celui ci comme en france
aussi comme en france écoutez on nous
parlons ici de législatives lorsque vous
voyez l'assemblée nationale qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils votent pas ce que
l'autre pas voter des lois pour kiki qui
écrase les petits et lorsque vous posez
ici vous prenez la ctm qu'est ce que
c'est la ctm c'est ni plus ni moins
qu'une assemblée composée alors c'est
ainsi certains disent que c'est un
mariage contre nature mais ya rien de
contre nature l'adar gestion pour jour
il est nommé dans les affaires
martiniquaise qui fait son beurre sur
dans toute cette affaire
je rappelle un petit peu quand même que
monsieur marie 7 lors de l'élection a
brandi fièrement une déclaration
communiquée de monsieur boudreau n'a
fausse marin on ne peut pas soupçonner
celui-là d'être de gauche 1 1 dix ans
bah écoutez c'est une très bonne chose
donc on ne peut pas soupçonner ces
personnes d'être du côté des
travailleurs
quel regard portez-vous sur l'activité
de nos parlementaires de ceux qui
doivent être leurs vendanges dangereux
prochain ben je note qu'il y a eu un
comité pour soutenir monsieur valls et
on retrouve là dedans un certain nombre
de parlementaires
monsieur à 0 monsieur letchimy monsieur
antiste monsieur larcher
je note que toutes ces personnes là font
partie de ce comité de soutien n'est pas
cité dès lors et barry janyk trouve un
peu plus grâce à vos yeux
pas du tout parce que ici il collabore
d'une autre manière avec le patronat
local via monsieur mon plaisir via
madame diane montrose donc vous savez il
s'agit tout simplement de même groupe et
vous paraît pas reparler de ces
parlementaires
je veux les dix au départ ce sont des
gens qui passent leur temps à soutenir
la politique du gouvernement a voté des
lois contre les travailleurs et qui donc
ne peuvent pas aujourd'hui prétendre
défendre les intérêts politiques des
travailleurs les idées que vous
défendent aujourd'hui gabriel jean marie
séides ans était celle des partis
socialiste et communiste à leurs
origines il n'y a plus rien qui pourrait
vous rapprocher des dirigeants de ces
formations actuelles écoutez monsieur
viol dont je vais vous dire un monsieur
hollande a prononcé un discours en
janvier 2012 il était alors candidat à
la présidentielle elle a dit mon agrès
bourges 7h au bourget 22 janvier 2012 si
ma mémoire est bonne cela dit je suis
mon adversaire n'a pas de visage pas de
nom ne se pense être à jamais à
l'élection mon avenir ça sur le monde de
la finance
qu'est ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
part de responsabilité là mais il a payé
très cher on lui reprocher un pacte de
responsabilité là ni le cic eux la loi
rebsamen la loi mâcon la loi travail 45
milliards de déverser dans les coffres
des possédants il ya des statistiques
qu'on ne donne pas l'année dernière il
ya eu 56 milliards de dividendes de
distribuer aux entreprises du cac 40 et
vous prenez quelqu'un comme bernard
arnault en cinq ans sa fortune a doublé
évalue aujourd'hui à 39 milliards
d'accord qui prévoit ce temps des
petites retraites
et pendant ce temps les petites
retraites alors vous savez il y à ce
monsieur marchand le cycliste à 2 105
ans vous savez combien ils gagnent qui
vient de base core qui vient de bâton au
corps 820 euros par mois il a été reçu
n'ya pas longtemps pour monsieur
hollande
il a fait une leçon à monsieur hollande
il a dit je ne voulais pas y aller ma
retraite a augmenté de 20 centimes at il
dit tu l'aidés en dernière année je
répète 45 milliards de déverser dans les
coffres des patrons alors vous avez je
voudrais quand même revenir parce que
vous avez fait une référence au parti
socialiste parti communiste il y a des
années au tout départ oui les partis
communistes et socialistes avaient des
principes mais vous savez au fur et à
mesure a eu cette dérive
et puis ceux qui dirigent ont tellement
fréquentes et les possédants qu'ils sont
devenus les fidèles serviteurs
d'où cette dérive que nous avons joué
on trouve par exemple que ce soit au
niveau français reçoit au niveau local
tous ces partis qui sont à la
disposition des possédants monsieur
mélenchon ne trouve pas grâce à vos yeux
monsieur mélenchon il faut savoir qu
elle s'est soumise afin de questionner
la france insoumise on propose de
changer le les choses avec des élections
attendez regardez monsieur obama va
partir là qu'est ce qu'il se passe mais
monsieur troupes a dit je vais défaire
leurs obamacare il y a eu des lois qui
ont été votées mais d'autres lois
peuvent défaire ce ne sont pas des
élections qui vont changer quoi que ce
soit ce sont des luttes et des buts
importante des nombreuses ou des
travailleurs ne mèneront pas des luttes
isolément vont se lier pour pouvoir
faire avancer les choses mais depuis le
temps que vous le dites pourquoi cette
lutte là ne s'organise pas pour aider
pas plus grands ne l'est pas plus
imposante puisque selon vous seuls 70
représentera une perspective d'avenir
pour la société dans son ensemble oui
c'est vrai mais il faut savoir que ce ne
sont pas nous les militants de combat
ouvrier ou d'autres seulement qui
pouvons appuyer sur un bouton pour dit
on va déclencher il y a que les
travailleurs doivent en prendre
conscience ils n'en sont pas encore à ce
stade nous les accompagnons nous
discutons est-ce que les martiniquais
sont un peu sont réglés comme on dit par
la tonalité de la campagne que nous
observons les conditions désignation de
hausser de tel ou tel parti telle ou
telle personne des affaires privées de
tels candidats qu'on en parle autant ça
se fait au détriment de la question de
fond mais bien sûr vous savez il y a un
rêve jackie healy à un sociologue qui a
10 ans quand on parle des poux faire
diversion on va parler des faits divers
donc on ne parle pas du fond le fond
c'est quoi le font par exemple votre
collègue tout à l'heure en a parlé dans
le cadre du journal ce sont par exemple
des salariés sont licenciés pour la
fermeture d'hyper u donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a des personnes qui vont venir
gonfler le nombre de chômeurs de ces
problèmes là on n'entend pas parler
nous agirons par crainte de l'emploi de
la cherté de la vie de la sécurité n'ont
écouté parler de l'emploi si proposer de
véritables solutions ai pas parlé d'
accompagnement d'accord vos propositions
à vous je termine vous avez par exemple
les prix des carburants qui ont augmenté
de 19 % quand même sur le gasoil
d'accord plus près de 1900 team 19
centimes 19% puisqu'il était de 1 euro
il est passé à 1 euro 19 19% mais
d'accord vous avez les
les impôts dans le sud on entend
beaucoup parler mais c'est votre
collègue m'a parlé de ce papier café
votre collègue monsieur partie 35% on ne
parle pas des raisons pour lesquelles
les impôts augmentent il faut dire celui
ci mais non pas du tout mais non pas du
tout vu qu'il faut dire sur ce qu'il
faut dire que c'est parce que le
gouvernement a décidé de ne pas verser
des ressources aux collectivités de
prendre cet argent pour le verser dans
le cadre du cic et du pack de
responsabilité que les collectivités
sont privés de hausse
résultat les politiques d'ici plutôt que
de dénoncer la politique du gouvernement
est un pays
des poches pays les petits c'est pour
cette raison qu'on en arrive là donc il
faut financer effectivement des services
publics
ah ben on va piller les petits il en
vint pas exiger du gouvernement qu'il
arrête de verser de l'argent public dans
les entreprises privées qui affiche
clairement après leur santé financière
alors vous débutez vous ferez croire ben
ou députés on a au moins l'honnêteté de
le dire c'est que un député ne changera
rien du tout et vous y avez bien on y va
on y va ou pas facile de rajouter
aujourd'hui par exemple vous nous offrez
la possibilité de nous exprimer et de
défendre un programme communiste un
programme de lutte et c'est pour cette
raison que nous sommes là nous disons
aux uns et aux autres aux petites gens
qui nous écoutent aux chômeurs aux
jeunes sans travail
nous leur disons lorsque vous apporterez
votre bulletin combat ouvrier lutte
ouvrière
vous ne votez pas pour qu'un grand on
prend un justicier viennent faire
justice votez sur un programme vous dit
nous sommes d'accord avec ce programme
nous allons nous compter combien pense
que effectivement faire passer par là je
séchais voyelles jean-marie ben écoutez
au sein de combat ouvrier ça fait 34 ans
oui et c'est toujours avec la même
ferveur oui vous avez la même ferveur
mais ça fait 34 ans que vous comptez
aussi le nombre de blocs glissé sous
votre nom sous le seul nom de votre
formation vous savez monsieur viol temps
je vais vous dire il y a une grande
élection qui s'est passé il ya il n'y a
pas très longtemps c'était en février
mars 2009 vous savez c'est ce type
d'élection là qu'il faut recommencer ça
fait pschitt
ça n'a pas fait pschitt monsieur v
autant c'était une répétition prix les
prix sont repartis mais non monsieur le
temps je vais vous dire ça recommençait
césar va recommencer
vous savez vous savez ça va recommencer
à va recommencer parce que vous savez il
n'ya pas que nous à le dire il n'y a pas
que nous à le dire il y à un employeur
je ne citerai pas son nom mais qui d'aïn
récemment il a dit 2009 à recommencer
notre mission à nous si je peux dire
c'est d'expliquer aux travailleurs que
nous devons nous regrouper discuter de
manière à pouvoir faire aboutir par des
luttes important nos revendications
gabriel jean marie candidat de combat
ouvrier dans la circonscription du sud
merci d'avoir été se remettre avec nous
dans son caddie bonne journée merci nous
avons reçu